[Musique]
encouragements être effectivement plus
rigoureux on m'a particulièrement touché
et donc j'ai décidé de me votre
encouragement de naître et donc nous
avons un enfant de grandes difficultés
réussi à identifier un certain nombre de
manifestants effectivement le statut
l'empêchant je les ai faits convoqués et
j'envisage de prendre vis-à-vis de deux
fonctions
[Musique]
vous voyez pas de sujets sur les
manifestations appelées par les
organisations syndicales quand elles ne
sont pas déclarés ou je pense notamment
manifestation des policiers récemment la
nuit depuis trois nuits de suite devant
les institutions
je n'ai pas trouvé les organisateurs
c'est entendu
[Musique]
n'a pas arrêté les ordinateurs s'est
déroulé par contre il convoque 36
policiers derrière
il se trouve que les organisateurs des
lancers de menottes et autres agitations
de voir des institutions bien aussi ils
étaient auditionnés
sauf que c'était dans un cadre syndical
de discussion donc oui il y à bien deux
poids deux mesures
[Musique]